légal tonnes depuis pas l'une aux halles
le 8 décembre
rendons au nom à cedar qui est à césar
l'idée originale et des et de jamel
debbouze on n'aurait pas question ici
tandian elle ouais c'est vrai pour avis
s'est déjà d'ailleurs c'est lui qui a eu
l'idée de faire les dalton le film qui a
racheté les droits par ugc et qui
finalement comme il voulait pas faire
astérix boule et bill les dalton et
cetera et cetera il et il s'est mis en
retrait et il nous a adorablement
laisser là une autre explication n'est
figé il est génial et génial et notre
projet le c'est l'album de la maturité
exactement ma fait le maximum terre on
peut le critiquer comme on veut on peut
dire ce qu'il veut ce qu'on veut du film
c'est on est au maximum de notre talent
on peut pas plus et si on nous dit là
oui là c'est un peu nul ça entre berne
et c'est tout ce qu'on sait faire de
nous serrer au maximum
désolé et franchement c'est c'est eh
bien quoi si je marche pas vous arrêter
quoi non continue
c'est la promesse d une halte quand on
lit les daltons les daltons plaqué sur
l'écran alors en 2005 the les rester
sous les feux de la rampe puisque vous
allez faire votre nouveau spectacle
eric et ramzy c'est ça en personne c'est
parce que c'est une femme seule personne
en fait elle affiche génial assez gentil
la fiche c'est absolument génial on la
voit pendant que je parle magie de la
télévision de dire qu'ils étaient
ensemble tout le temps comme vous ne le
faites remarquer à chaque fois quand
vous recevoir plus que nos femmes que
c'est un mélange maintenant il n'y a
plus vraiment de eric tu vraiment de ram
dit ça y est on pense la même chose
on mange la même chose en fusion quoi
bahia une dire quoi fusion très veux
dire par là franchement sexuels anaux
n'y a pas d'exclusion est-ce que vous
pouvez répondre en même temps par
exemple eric et ramzy comment vous vous
sentez très bien bien mais là et copier
les parties sur bien eric et ramzy vous
n'êtes plus qu'à vous avez fusionner les
copines vivent ça commence très mal
ça change quoi d'avoir un cerveau pour
de sa race ou lavage s'étaient reposés
on se repose
maintenant qu'ils allaient fusionner qui
contrôle la [ __ ] un pilote on a embauché
une troisième qui dirige un nouveau
spectacle coécrit avec michel
hazanavicius qui a fait la classe le cn
legrand détournent et qui a écrit les
dalton voilà ça y est une affaire qui
marche
et c'est surtout en fait on se rendait
compte que on arrêtait la scène ya
longtemps et quand il est dans la rue
ont malgré les films qu'on sortait les
18 films ouvriers insulter les gens nous
disaient alors c'est quand sur scène on
fait un an que j'ai là il ya un film qui
arrive dans des camps donc on se rend
bien compte que il faut tourner sur
scène